la cérémonie d'AD Dieu s'est tenue au
funérarium de Saint-Pierre dans
l'intimité un suit de la famille il n'y
aura pas d'image la petite chapelle
était trop petite pour accueillir les
amis les nombreuses personnalités
politiques mais aussi des chanteurs
venus rendre un dernier hommage à
Claudine avec bon la simplicité comme un
vrai artiste
la pas dentelle le
vrai
l'authentique c'est ça pour Mo Claudine
c'est ça Claudine bien sû la B mais
c'est vraiment un plaisir une fraîch
avec Claudine quand
ch une très grande artiste qui s'en
Claudine c'était une amie bon on a
travaillé ensemble on a joué ensemble
avec Jacqueline et puis il y a
énormément de souvenirs quoi et puis et
puis si jeune 52
ans2 en effet 62 ans emportés par une
maladie Claudine restera dans les cœurs
on é ensemble dans presque tout le pays
du mondeut dire avec bien sûr avec le
goût folklorique et avec ses amis à la
fin j'étais venu plusieurs fois le voir
c'est un gros gros une grosse plte pour
moi c'est c'est une sœur c'est une amie
au lendemain de la disparition de
Claudine Tarby des admirateurs des
anonymes dans les rues de La Plaine des
Cafres se souviennent de l'artiste grand
cœur quand il fait que manger n danse
avec si on lu entend la musique ouais
super ou et et Claudine c'était une
chanteuse oui une chanteuse et avant vu
avec Jaine Farol et ben pour moi ben
j'ai pas connu vraiment Claudine mais en
tant que quand j'étais à l'école pas
jeune c'était c'éta c'était le groupe
quoi disc un pe souventve
avec quelqu'un vraiment familiil es
vraiment de famille la chanteuse du
groupe a rejoint les étoiles